this is an episode that's been almost
one year in the making the theo locution
of donald hoffman and yoshibok both of
whom should be extremely familiar to you
if you've surveyed this channel before
as we've done an unduly technical dive
into donald hoffman's research papers
and we've spoken to yoshibach several
times before as well if you're
unfamiliar donald hoffman is a professor
at the university of irvine california
studying consciousness and evolutionary
psychology using mathematical models and
yoshibak is a cognitive scientist
recognized in the field of ai as being
exceptionally ingenious both have
unexampled views of consciousness and
free will which harmonize and contradict
in pre-possessing and informative ways
click on the timestamp in the
description if you'd like to skip this
intro my name is kirchey mungle i'm a
torontonian filmmaker with a background
in mathematical physics dedicated to the
explication of the variegated terrain of
theories of everything from a
theoretical physics perspective but as
well as analyzing consciousness and
seeing its potential connection to
fundamental reality whatever that is
essentially this channel is dedicated to
exploring the under nature of reality
the constitutional laws that govern it
provided those laws exist at all and are
even noble to us if you enjoy witnessing
and engaging with others on the topics
of psychology consciousness physics etc
the channel's themes then do consider
going to the discord and the subreddit
which are linked in the description
there's also a link to the patreon that
is patreon.com
kerchamungle if you'd like to support
this podcast as the patrons and the
sponsors are the only reasons that i'm
able to have podcasts of this quality
and this depth given that i can do this
now full time thanks to both the patrons
and the sponsors support speaking of
sponsors there are two the first sponsor
is brilliant during the winter break i
decided to brush up on some of the
fundamentals of physics particularly
with regard to information theory as i'd
like to interview chiara marletto on
constructor theory which is heavily
based in information theory now
information theory is predicated on
entropy at least there's a fundamental
formula for entropy so i ended up taking
the brilliant course i challenged myself
to do one lesson per day and i took the
course's random variable distributions
and knowledge
uncertainty what i loved is that despite
knowing the formula for entropy which is
essentially hammered into you as an
undergraduate it seems like it comes
down from the sky arbitrarily and with
brilliance for the first time i was able
to see how the formula for entropy which
you're seeing right now is actually
extremely natural and it'd be strange to
define it in any other manner there are
plenty of courses and you can even learn
group theory which is what's being
referenced when you hear that the
standard model is predicated on u1 cross
su 2 cross su 3 those are league groups
continuous lead groups visit
brilliant.org
tow t-o-e to get 20 off an annual
subscription and i recommend that you
don't stop before four lessons i think
you'll be greatly surprised at the ease
at which you can now comprehend subjects
you previously had a difficult time
grocking the second sponsor is algo now
algo is an end-to-end supply chain
optimization software company with
software that helps business users
optimize sales and operations planning
to avoid stockouts reduce return and
inventory write-downs while reducing
inventory investment it's a supply chain
ai that drives smart roi headed by amjad
hussein who's been a huge supporter of
this podcast since near its inception in
fact amjad has his own podcast on ai and
consciousness and business growth and if
you'd like to support the tow podcast
then visit the link in the description
to see amjad's podcast because
subscribing to him or at least visiting
supports the toe podcast indirectly
thank you and enjoy
okay this should be live if you can see
this type in animaniacs into the chat
animaniacs
great there are already 275 people
watching firstly it's a distinct honor
to be here thank you both don and yosha
i appreciate it tremendously in the
audience does as well this theories of
everything
project is about exploring grand unified
theories in theoretical physics as you
know and understanding consciousness and
free will i see those are at least
intuit that those are integrally tied
and it's those
the latter two topics that bring us here
don
why don't we start with your definition
of free will as well as how you view
consciousness and you mentioned that you
would like to give an overview of your
point of view on science and theories of
everything in general
and then yosha
you'll join afterward and commend
donald or amend him and then i'll pretty
much shut my mouth and allow you both to
speak to one another interjecting only
seldom
okay thank you kurt and good to see you
yosha um
my my attitude about science
is
sort of like what
newton famously said
right he said that toward the end of his
career that he thought of himself as
like
a little boy
playing on the on the seashore looking
at uh some nice
pebbles and shells while
all before him lay the um
the vast ocean of of truth that was
undiscovered
and
and i you know i think that that's a
good attitude for us as scientists to
have is that
as much as we've done
um
we've really not even begun to explore
the possibilities of truth and what's
interesting is that newton's followers
uh famously
didn't
follow him on that
in the late
19th century a lot of newtonians thought
that it was pretty much over they had a
theory of everything
there were a few little wrinkles
you know there was the you know
problem with michaelson morally
experiment and
and black body radiation wasn't quite
working out
according to newton but they thought
that that was pretty minor stuff and
they would figure that all out and
physics was pretty much done
and and we've discovered that no physics
would was hardly
beginning there was so much more to
discover and so my attitude is that
science
cannot have a theory of everything
in principle
that we will always be on newton's
seashore we'll always be
like newton the the little boy playing
with pebbles and
and shells while the vast uh truth lays
undiscovered before us the ocean of
truth and and it's for a principled
reason
that
scientific theories
if you look at how
they're structured we start with
a good scientific theory tells you
exactly what its assumptions are this is
what i'm assuming
these are the derivation rules that i
allow
and then everything about the theory
follows from that but that that theory
doesn't explain its assumptions the
assumptions are what's
assumed so einstein in this special
theory of relativity assumes you know
that light
uh travels at the same speed for for all
observers in all inertial reference
frames
but
that theory doesn't tell you what light
is
and in fact einstein spent his whole
life wondering what light is and toward
the end of his life said i've spent my
whole life studying it and i still have
no idea what what light really is
and and so
we're in that situation as scientists
where
um what we're doing is valuable it's
it's absolutely essential because we're
being precise about our assumptions
we're being precise about what they
entail
but there's going to be a fundamental
limit and and
my guess is that science
um as valuable as it is is one of the
most
important advances that humanity has
made
um will always and only scratch the
surface beyond the seashore with with
newton while the vast ocean um lays
undiscovered and um so that that's sort
of when so when we talk about theories
of consciousness and free will and so
forth going forward
i do it with sort of a very modest look
at my own ideas the the ideas are going
to be very much
in
the framework of these are the best
ideas we've come up with so far
of course
there's going to be much much deeper
work ahead um and much more to to
discover ahead so we just have to
as scientists be precise about the
current assumptions we're making and why
we're making them and what what follows
from them but be completely open to
radical
transformations in knowledge and radical
new understandings
your view on consciousness and free will
so
um
in in a nutshell
um my views on consciousness
are
are not physicalist
so
so physicalist approaches we'll say that
we will start with space-time
and and some of its contents
particles neurons neural systems neural
networks that
um
and
those will be so that's a scientific
theory which those are our assumptions
space time and its contents are
fundamental
and particular contents may be very very
important for example dynamical systems
of
on neural networks for example
and from that we're going to try to to
boot up um
subjective experience um
and and that's perfectly a fine project
to try to do uh what we you know what i
would want from that physicalist
approach would be um
not a hand wave but but a specific
accomplishment so you know how do we
start with um dynamical systems of
neural networks and come up with the
taste of chocolate
or the smell of garlic or something
specific some specific conscious
experience but we say my my scientific
theory says why this
dynamical system of activity in
neurons or in computer system or
something like that must be the taste of
chocolate it could not be the smell of
garlic and these are the principal
reasons why if we if something like that
were on the table i would be impressed
until then i'm not impressed
so so
and there's nothing on the table uh yet
that can do that
so that's one reason why i've been
casting around and and looking for a
different direction
um it's not starting with the with the
physical
but starting um somewhere else and
partly because and we can talk about
this in greater detail
because our best scientific theories
right now namely um
[Music]
quantum field theory and and general
relativity on the one hand
and an evolution of natural selection on
the other
both
entail
that space-time is not fundamental
our our two
or three premier scientific theories
um really tell us
their limits
they tell us that space time cannot be
fundamental
and that therefore the contents of space
time are not fundamental
and so if we're going to look for a
theory of consciousness
and we start with something inside space
time we're already starting where our
best scientific theories tell us
is not fundamental
so as a result i've been trying to then
say well if space time isn't fundamental
and we don't yet know
what's more fundamental
why don't we first start with trying to
get a mathematical theory of
consciousness on its own terms
what is consciousness
what kinds of assumptions can we make
about it
and then we can ask the question you
know is consciousness
more fundamental than space-time what is
the relationship between consciousness
and space-time
so so the you know the and i can go in
in some of the details if we want to on
on that model um but but the big picture
is that um
[Music]
i'm taking very seriously that evolution
of natural selection entails that none
of our
sensory systems tell us the truths about
objective reality and that therefore
space time is is
not an objective truth it's just
a
a representation of fitness payoffs
and that
physicists are finding the same thing
that nima or kanye hamed for example at
the institute for advanced study
princeton basically
has lectures where he says space time is
doomed and here's why
and the best physicists are now trying
to figure out what's next space time has
had a good run for several centuries and
it's over
space time is not fundamental and the
contents of space time are not
fundamental and so we need to figure out
and he's got things with you working
with juan maul the cena on things like
cosmological polytopes they're finding
structures beyond space-time from which
space-time can emerge as as a as a
projection
as a special case but these in these in
these deeper
theories there is no time
and there is no space
but there are symmetries that are true
of for example scattering amplitudes
data
that that are there that are true that
you can't see in space time they they
can predict the data but they don't use
space and time as the fundamental
concepts and i think that
as we start to go into
your scientific theories of
consciousness
we cannot ignore what our physicist
colleagues are telling us
they're they're telling us if you're
looking for something fundamental it's
not space time and in particular it's
not time
and that that is a real show stopper is
it's for the physicist too i mean trying
to think outside of the time box
is not easy for the physicists and so
what do we do if we don't have
um space time if we don't have
time
so so i think that that's
one of the interesting questions that we
have to face if we're going to come up
with a theory of consciousness what do
we take as fundamental in our theory if
we take anything inside space time
we're already sort of cutting ourselves
off
because we know that as physics
progresses
things inside space time will just be um
shown to be secondary
so we can go into my details on on
you know my current model of
consciousness but maybe we should talk
first about these more meta ideas
sure and joshua please
and it's interesting that you start
outing yourself as a mysterianist in a
way right the mysterianism being the
position that human minds are basically
not equipped to understand how they work
or how the universe works that they are
embedded in at a very deep level
and i sometimes joke that mysterianism
is the position that something cannot be
understood if it cannot be understood by
norm chomsky
with respect to the mind at the science
of consciousness conference he once uh
gave a presentation where he uh talks
about the card and then mentions that
the card was actually a very smart
fellow because you could already
anticipate stuff that would only be
discovered much much later on and i was
perking up and wondering my god chomsky
is giving this guy credit
and it turned out what he anticipated
was that
we would later like tomski discover that
the mind is unintelligible
right so uh this
it's fascinating of course if you are
one of the smartest minds of your own
generation and you see that other people
don't understand
things and that you understand and there
is a boundary where nobody seems to have
an understanding and you crash against
it you you might think okay maybe there
is no way that humans can do it
not convinced that this is the case
though so i'm not i'm not a mysterianist
at this point in my intellectual career
and that's in part because i come from
the other side so many of the things
that
people took as a given for a long time
like space and time
appeared to me in the beginning quite
mysterious
so
basically the dissolution of space and
time was not that mysterious to me
basically i'm a computer scientist i
started very very early on in my life to
program before i properly understood
mathematics and before i understood
physics
and i understood how to make things in a
computer and
einstein's watch
that is
taking away and you can observe its
movements and so on but you cannot open
it and you can come up with theories
what's happening inside to me this watch
was the screen of a computer
and i understood that there is no limit
to what can be put into the computer if
uh it has enough resources right so if
the computer is fast enough and if it
has enough memory there is no pattern
that cannot be shown on the screen there
is no limit to the sequence of patterns
that is to be shown on the screen so any
observation that i am making if i
understand it as a pattern on some kind
of screen that is visible to me i will
always be able to construct something a
mechanism that is on the other side and
produces the sequence
and now the question is can i produce an
elegant sequence can i produce a minimal
pattern can i produce something from
which i think it's plausible that it
emerged by itself
and that is to me this big important
question of physics the idea of
physicalism to me is the notion that
we live in a reality that is fully
emergent over a causally closed
mechanical layer and we are in that base
reality that emerges from it
and the alternatives to physicalism is
that this base layer is somewhere else
because even if we live in a simulation
that is created by some kind of
supernatural being
something must have created the
supernatural being in its parent
universe right so ultimately every
supernatural event is going to have some
kind of natural cause some kind of prime
mover that is taking away in the void
and producing the patterns that you
observe and the patterns that you
observe are so damn regular and there is
all this conservation going on
of information that uh it
doesn't seem like a conspiracy to me it
seems that we are not in a simulation it
seems that the idea that consciousness
could be primary to our reality is not
true because consciousness being primary
means that you would have to live in
somebody else's mind
that we live in some kind of
conspirational simulation that somebody
has set up for us and well that is
possible and i can principal not exclude
it because there can be no evidence that
can ever be fully conclusive if somebody
sets it up to deceive me
there is no reason for me to believe it
because there are not enough things
happening in my reality that counteract
the notion that i live in a mechanical
universe the few things that pop up i
can still explain this by faulty
memories and psychosis
right so the only thing that uh needs to
be explained and that i was puzzling
people like turing and other thinkers is
there's a possibility that telepathy is
true
if that is would be true right we it
would not be compatible with the way in
which we understand physics right now
and there's this question is there a
point at which we have to discard
physics fully and accept that you live
in some kind of simulation in some kind
of dream universe that somebody has set
up like a computer game where you can
arbitrarily break hostility when it's
convenient or is this uh something that
we need to extend physics or is it just
something where our minds are playing
tricks with us and we know our mindset
playing lots of tricks with us
so during considered the possibility
that telepathy exists as very real to
this to the point where he included this
in his 1950 paper computing machinery
and intelligence where he sketches out
the tubing test
and seriously asks what a turing test
would have to involve or such a system
the ability to
be telepathic and if it's not what
difference would it make it doesn't get
to the point where you assess out loud
that
if telepathy is possible you cannot be
sure which of your thoughts and feelings
originate in your own brain they could
come from somewhere else right so
this opens up the door to lots and lots
of things
but uh for the time being
i think that uh the evidence for
telepathy is weak and if uh telepathy
would exist um i would be seriously
willing to consider this together with
during uh this is not clear why whether
we cannot find a mechanical explanation
for it
but there's always going to be some kind
of computer program that explains the
patterns on the screen
now if we think about space
to me as a
kit that was programming the notion of a
continuous space never made sense
because it's not computable i cannot
write something that is continuous space
and when i tried to wrap my mind around
the mathematics
the language broke i was not able to
understand how to make a point that is
infinitely small yet fits together if
you add infinitely many of these points
into a continuum
this just doesn't work right
but it's not a problem to make something
that exactly looks like this it's not a
problem to make a computer game that
looks continuous it's not a computer
game that produces physics that looks
similar to what we can observe at least
in the simplification of course our
computers are extremely inefficient when
it comes
to simulating
the substrate layer the quantum
mechanics that we can observe or a layer
below the quantum mechanics if because
quantum mechanics is probably not the
the lowest layer in which physics plays
out it's just the lowest layer in which
we can currently make observations that
we can conceptualize
and this leads us to what you also
mentioned
what is the photon i don't think that
einstein started out with the assumption
that the speed of light is fixed i think
it was a derivation that he made he
concluded that the speed of light is
fixed
and
he basically once he had this conclusion
he had implications for the possible
descriptions of space-time that emerged
because uh when the speed of light is
fixed you end up with some very
interesting paradoxes if you stay in a
newtonian universe right you have this
issue imagine you fly in a very fast
spaceship and you are lighting uh
putting light out of your flashlight
inside of your spaceship wouldn't the
speed of light necessarily add up to the
speed of the spaceship to an external
observer
right so wouldn't this external observer
not need to observe a different speed of
light than the person traveling in a
spaceship and if the speed of light is
constant always
it means
that the thing that now it has to change
is time or space or both
right you can still fix this if you make
sure that the speed of
time runs in a different way and this
leads us to the inside
that the time and space that we observe
from our own perspectives as at merchant
observer and whatever universe produces
us
are interdependent they're not
independent of each other the speed of
light depends on the trajectory that the
the speed of time depends on the
trajectory that you are taking through
the universe
and
if you want to think about something
that could be more fundamental
we would say that the photon is a
carrier of a
of the electromagnetic force it's a type
of boson which means it can be described
as a certain pattern that has an integer
spin
and it has the property
that it
is describing the potential lte for
measuring some electromagnetic
interaction
so if we take space time from the
perspective of the observer it's the set
of locations that can contain
information
and the set of trajectories that the
information can take and the photon is a
model of information traveling through
space-time
and what we have discovered and what
einstein also sometimes suspected
is that space itself cannot be
fundamental
and there were concrete reasons to to
see this because what was discovered
during einstein's career even when he
was
aware of this discovery was that there
were singularities in spacetime which
means points at where the mathematics of
continuous space breaks down so your
mathematics doesn't work anymore you
have some kind of a division by zero
something unpleasant happens where your
mathematics is no longer valid
and what einstein saw is that we can fix
this by
shifting the singularities around in our
spaces type model
and we can basically put them below the
carpet
you can put them in centers of mass
so in the center of mars there is
basically something like little black
hole where mathematics doesn't work
anymore the mathematics of space time
where your mathematical description of
that world doesn't work anymore
and what could be more fundamental than
space-time i think it could be
transitions so you describe the universe
as some kind of state vector set of
information and this information is
dynamic you have the way in which
information moves between the locations
and in this paradigm the speed of light
could be uh the rate at which
information propagates between locations
and this would be an upper limit of all
interactions that you observe
within this
lattice versus staff is densely
connected
what would it what would be necessary to
if you have a set of locations some kind
of graph and causal graph and
information flowing between them to
understand that there is causal
structure well you need to understand
where the information comes from to
understand what it signifies so you can
model it how can a single bit mean
anything to you if it's just a single
bit if it's not attached with the source
with the type with the context
right so what could be a way to figure
out where information comes from well it
needs to have some kind of momentum some
kind of direction
to carry information about direction
and you send this to the graph that by
itself just has just locations
connections the only way that you can do
this is if this thing is extended if
it's not just a single location so which
the information propagates but if it's
neighboring connections and you get
information that verifies it so you need
to be in some kind of densely strong
letters for information that you can
pinpoint
basically you need to have something
that looks like a continuous space so
you can identify controllable structure
that you can identify where uh stuff
comes from like a photon
and uh if there is information that is
traveling across distance so to speak
that this is non-local that is not going
through densely connected local
connections but that is going over
individual long-range links this
information will look like a random
fluctuation or a distant entanglement
that you can no longer track if you
don't know where it originated
and this would will look like something
like
in determinism in from your local
observer perspective
still you would uh not be in
contradiction to the
preservation of information it would
still be a universe in which information
is not invented but in which the amount
of discernible information is constant
and if the universe was not in such a
way that information would be preserved
of course it would not be learnable
because it would mean that the present
state of the universe
is forgetting what happened before in
the universe it gets disconnected the
world line of the universe just gets
disconnected and so from an
epistemological perspective we can only
learn the aspects of the universe that
look like they are conserved if there
are things in the universe that are not
conserved then they will not be
intelligible to us
and of course it's conceivable that the
universe is some kind of automaton that
forgets information
another thing that shows us that
space-time cannot be fundamental besides
um
about theorem which destroys the notion
of locality is the notion of the
collapse of the wave function basically
this
collapse of the wave function is the
point
in the history of an observer beyond
which we cannot
obtain a model
of locations of events in time and space
right beyond that point it's no longer
not just that we don't have enough
information to construct it but it makes
no sense anymore to assume that the
photon was at a particular point when it
went to the double slit
right at this point the space-time model
breaks down the space-time model is a
mathematical abstraction
that works relatively well to look at
things happening in the limit
but it's not a model that can be
fundamental i think
and but i'm not a physicist so i'm not
actually qualified to have these
opinions this is just what it looks like
to me as a computer scientist who tries
to understand the mind and things like
donald that
we have to
understand a certain degree of physics
to make sure that our theories of
consciousness are tight and that they
make sense and to have to understand in
which way they could possibly relate to
physics
i'm less convinced that donald that a
deep understanding of physics is
necessary or that physics is going to
teach us about consciousness in part
because i don't think that consciousness
is that mysterious anymore i spent a lot
of
time in my life
thinking that it was mysterious but
seems to be a riddle that can be solved
and uh basically i think that there's
some aspects to consciousness for
instance that you that you're observing
yourself to be observing but uh
consciousness is
something that is entirely virtual it's
not a physical thing
electrons photons
physical entities neurons brains cannot
be conscious they're just mechanisms
and
what we can see is that the elements of
our consciousness are not mechanical
they're magical somehow there is magic
happening
and if there is magic happening it means
that it's an a causal structure it's
something that has been made on some
kind of causal loom but that is not
necessarily built in the same mechanical
way as physics is built
it's a story it's a it's a tale being
told by a physical system to itself
and if you think about organisms you
often think of them as physical systems
and they're neither right the organism
doesn't exist it's not the same
if you think about it what exists are
cells that interact with each other and
even the cells don't really exist what
exists are molecules and even the
molecules don't really exist right
they're all layers of descriptions
they're models that we can make because
they're coherent
and they hold to some degree
it might be frazzling out at the
boundaries but there are ways of
thinking about the flow of information
in the universe
and the organism is a coherent pattern
that you observe in the interaction
between cells and the cells have been
set up by evolution to interact in this
coherent pattern because when they
interact as if they were driven by a
single spirit by a single target by a
single telos and if their behavior is
coherent and consistent that are state
building then they have an advantage
over cells which don't do that and just
fight for themselves because together
they can play longer games
by playing longer games they can occupy
niches in nature that cannot be occupied
by control systems that play shorter
games
and this is the benefit that organisms
have these coordinations between cells
and an organism is a function that
describes this pattern in the cells
and the organism is facilitated by
information processing across cells
among other things
to coordinate its interactions the
organism needs to have something like a
telegraph network by which it's able to
make models of reality and coordinate
them between the cells and coordinate
the behavior of the cells
and in animals this telegraph system is
facilitated in large part by the nervous
system it would not be necessary that
the nervous system basically every cell
type can do this but if you want to make
it fast
you need to have specialized cells that
have a very quick expensive metabolism
and can send information over very long
distances very quickly which other cell
types cannot so neurons are a specific
type of cells that allow
particular kind of information
processing
and this information processing has the
property that they can put stuff on the
screen so it's some kind of computer
it's a thing that can produce arbitrary
sequences of patterns if it discovers a
suitable function to produce them and
implement them in the distributed
networks of cells
and part of what they're doing is that
they create a story
about a being that lives in the outside
world
and in our culture we have difficulty
understanding how that is because we
in our culture as a default teacher for
kids that what they see is the physical
world
and the physical world has sounds and
colors and so on only much later we tell
them well it's slightly more complicated
and sounds and color are not actually in
physics
everything that you consider to be
sounds and colors is photons photons
make electromagnetic interaction which
let air molecules push against each
other so they can form regular waves and
colors are
local dimensions that you get by
measuring sampling the frequency of the
electromagnetic spectrum using different
receptor types and making a model of
them using polar coordinates
right so this is something that we don't
tell the story fully to our children
which makes it even more confusing and
then we tell them uh photons are
actually not little billiard balls but
there are regions in the space time that
have a potential for an electromagnetic
interaction
and this space that you're talking about
is the photonic space it's the space
where you can possibly have photon
interactions for some reason it's
three-dimensional
and maybe there are other spaces that
are not three-dimensional and maybe in
these spaces you cannot have interacting
matter in the same way
because uh maybe um in order to get
stable objects you need to make little
nuts in the electromagnetic structure or
in the spatial structure and you cannot
make knots in 2d and in 4d they fall
apart so maybe that's the reason or
maybe there's another one and we haven't
completely figured it out yet and there
are some candidates that explain why the
space that we are in is
three-dimensional so why is it that we
are interacting with the photonic space
and not with the others why are the
others not seeming to form a connected
space
in this connected letters
um but we don't know the answer yet at
least i'm not aware of the work that is
sketching out the answer
and
if i stumble on it i i pray that i
understand it
but i think that there are other
cultures that have a better intuitive
understanding of what consciousness is
and if you look around we find that some
cultures don't find consciousness
mysterious i even suspect that in the
core of our own culture before the tower
of people that destroyed the shared
understanding it's still in there
so a little bit obsessed these days with
thinking about genesis in the bible and
read this epistemologically correct not
as a myth that is a stand in for an
origin theory until real science comes
along
but as something that is literally true
so what would that mean you know i'm
talking about the first book
i'm talking about um the book that
starts out with the creation of
sky and darkness and heaven and earth
and so on
and
they sing with the story if you take it
literally the way in which christianity
interprets it it's a story about a
supernatural being creating a physical
universe and what's wrong with the story
is that whoever tells it to you had no
evidence that it was true
right so there is no claim
if somebody makes a claim without
evidence you don't have to listen
it uh it could be interesting as a story
for cultural reference what could be
interesting as an idea for something
that you could test but if it's
principle not testable
this person cannot have that evidence
there is no secret source of knowledge
that this person had there is in
principle nothing that
that
some other person can update others with
some kind of back channel by talking to
a burning bush that could would
constitute a valid experiment so
uh
this reading makes no sense
it would never make any sense but it
could make sense especially if you
understand that
sky and ground
and light and sound and plants and
animals and their names don't actually
exist in physics
right they only exist in our mind as a
division of the universe into separate
objects so they become intelligible to
us
and the way in which we construct these
objects is inside of the mind so the
creation of the universe that is being
described in genesis is not the
physicalist universe with quantum
mechanics it's the creation of the
experimental universe in which we are
actually in in which we find ourselves
to be in
and the first thing that the mind is
discovering when it creates this
universe is how to make light
right how to uh create neural
oscillators that are creating a contrast
between light and darkness so separate
the light from the darkness and then
organize this into multiple dimensions
until you get a space
and then you align the space with the
information from your vestibular organs
and what you get
is the two-dimensional plane of the
ground and the three-dimensional space
of the sky above it
right so after you create light and
darkness you create literally every mind
does this in their cognitive development
the sky and the ground
and then you discover the objects in it
so you basically learn how to model
materials in your mind so you have
solids and you have liquids
and you have organic shapes and you have
animated agents
and then you discover features that you
cannot interact with like celestial
bodies
and anchor them in the world and you
learn how to navigate this world and
then you discover all the plants and the
animals or you construct them in your
mind and you associate them all with
their names so again of course not a
feature of the physical world they are
socially cons
exchanged these names and so on create
this world together and then
last
but not least
we create a person
so the thing that creates it is not a
person yet it's a mind that exists
before a person is around we don't
remember how we made light
we don't remember how we discovered the
sky and the ground in the first space
this was another observing agent in our
own brain
and this observing agent in our own
brain at some point discovers
the needs of a person of the needs of an
organism the organism that
its brain is embedded in
and it creates a model of that too
so it creates
an agent
that is observing this universe that is
embedded in this universe because this
first observer in our own mind is
discovering
that such an entity exists it's this
useful model to describe reality that
there is a person that has needs and
desires and social embedding and dreams
and hopes and memories and expectations
and it will create a story of that and
that story is just as real as the trees
that exist in our mind as imaginations
or the trees or um the uh that in the
forest and uh beyond the horizon and as
real as the sky and the clouds and the
colors and so on but they're all virtual
they're all simulacra they all exist to
tell a story to the organism that is
useful for the organism to model the
world
and this part where we become a person
seems to be happening i think around the
age of one and a half to two and a half
roughly in most children that i observed
and at this point a person that is
different from before emerges in their
mind it's not that there is nobody there
before it's just that this thing before
it's different
and you notice that there's a gap in
their memories they have memories when
they're
in the
first year when you talk to them
where they remember what happened
and have expectations already
but later on there is this point where
they don't remember these things anymore
it's very weird and most people when you
think back don't have memories that they
can consciously access between uh before
they're like two and a half years old
and so i wonder if this transition is
the result of just a re-indexing of
memories due to our newfound linguistic
ability so we can later on no longer
access these memories or if it's really
just uh basically a new agent that is
created by the first agent in its own
image
as an observer that is aware of the fact
that it's observing
and uh but in a different way as men and
women as something that thinks it's a
person that thinks it's a human being
and i'm not a human being i realize that
at some level i don't have an identity
as a human being this is a story that my
mind tells itself as an additional thing
my consciousness doesn't have an
identity
my consciousness is also not of the
nature that it's the same as everybody
else's consciousness right it's
the question do we all uh are the same
consciousness looking through different
eyes or with separate consciousnesses is
in some sense as meaningless as the
question of asking is the text editor
that you're running onto your computer
the same text editor that everybody else
runs on their computer
or is it a different one
right the program word is in some sense
a natural law if you put the circuits of
your computer in the same
functional configuration then
those things are going to happen with
the circuits of your computer and they
will afford the following interactions
but the program word doesn't have an
identity and it's also not that it has
no identity in the sense it's just not a
meaningful category to apply to it in
the same sense my consciousness is not
in in this category that would have an
identity or none
so it's it's not something that is
shared with others and it's not
something that is separate from others
it's a principle that applies to the
observation and when the consciousness
gets tied to a self-model then it
becomes perspectival and i have an
identity and so on but this identity is
a particular kind of model that my
organism tells itself by changing um
certain factors in my own brain
okay let's let don respond
yeah there's well there's quite a bit
there
um so on the
the nature of
the physical world and and in
computation
um
and the finiteness
versus you contin continuity of
spacetime and so forth
i think that
the work you know girdles incompleteness
theorem
is is very relevant here that
the notion of
truth
is far deeper than the notion of proof
there are
any system
any computational system will have
things that it can prove
but
there will be truths
that that computational system cannot
access
um and if you add those new truth add a
new truth of you know a girl's statement
to your set of axioms and there will be
yet more truths that cannot be accessed
from that that that
and so what you can compute
is always going to be trivial
to what
is true there will always be
as far as i can tell again is sort of
like newton's notion of we're at the
seashore and the vast ocean
of of of reality of the truth he
actually used the word truth the vast
ocean of truths is out there beyond what
we can compute and every truth that you
add to your base for computation um
doesn't solve the problem
and
and you might say well that's that's
true you know of abstract mathematics
but that's not true of physics
i mean the physics itself is computable
but that
um there's some recent work um
suggesting that that's that's not the
case so um
tony kubit
the physicist and and his colleagues
have have recently proved that
a very important problem to condense
matter physicists
called the spectral gap problem
um is not computable
and
that's that's a stunning result and they
also suspect and they're working on this
they haven't proven this yet but that
something that that's a big open problem
i think the millennium
prize committee has this is one of their
problems is to understand the the yang
mills gas gap
problem which is you know why do
photons and gravitons have no mass but
the
the carriers of the strong weak force do
have mass
and kubit and his
collaborators think again that we're
going to find that something
non-computational is going on here it's
not decidable
and my guess is that this is just the
beginning
that we're going to find that as
powerful as computation is and you know
i
i was in the artificial intelligence lab
at mit for my phd and i'm all for ai and
for computation and i you know
i think it's it's fabulous what
computation can do and and the naysayers
who think that the computation can't do
amazing things and artificial
intelligence can have you know important
limits that um i think that
the name i disagree with the naysayers
on the other hand i do believe girls
incompleteness theorem is correct
and i do think that um
the notion of truth is just vastly that
the notion the set of truths
um i'll put it this way the set of
things that we can prove from any system
is essentially probability zero
in the set of all truths in other words
we're always going to be as as newton
said on the seashore
with with computation and is for
principled reasons so it's not a
mysterianism
um that's not founded it's saying our
best theories tell us that truth and
proof are not the same thing
and that proofs will always only leave
you on the seashore
and so that that's why
i mean
i i didn't like that conclusion but you
know girdle proved it and now physicists
are finding it in you know the spectral
gap and so
as much as i like computation i'm a
computer scientist myself as much as i
like computation
i have to defer to the mathematical
proofs that say um computation goes thus
far and no further
and then ask myself okay
how can so my my conceptual system then
is itself
just a symbolic system
with derivation rules so what i what i
can compute by my my thought is also
going to be limited which is why i was
saying up front what i think about
scientific theories right scientific
theories are going to have these
limitations we will put down a set of
axioms
each theory a good scientific theory
will tell you exactly what it assumes
and
it will also give you a hint about the
kind of derivations that you can give
from those assumptions and then you use
you find what that theory will entail
but our best theories
uh like
quantum theory and relativity and
evolution of natural selection
the best theories will also tell you
where they stop they will say we go this
far and no further
and and for example
physics tells us
that
space time itself cannot be fundamental
that the very notion of space-time
cannot be fundamental which is stunning
because physics for several centuries
has essentially been the study of what
happens in space and time
and so to say that space time is not
fundamental
means that the physicists have to
redefine what what physics is about and
that's what for example juan maldocena
and neymar connie hamid are trying to do
with things like the cosmological
polytope and amplitude and so forth
they're finding
structures where there are no hilbert
spaces so there's no quantum theory
there is no time
there is no space
there are these positive geometries and
what you find is you can predict
events in space time like scattering
processes that you see at the large
hadron collider you can predict them and
in fact you
you can actually
compute them
in some sense better than if you assume
space time so they're finding that what
you know if you use feynman diagrams and
try to compute scattering amplitudes for
two gluons coming in and four gluons
scattering out using the standard
quantum field theoretic approaches where
space and time is assumed you get
hundreds of pages of algebra and it's
it's it's a mask whereas if you let go
space time and and look at these
structures
uh with symmetries that cannot be
expressed in space timeline dual
conformal symmetry then you find that
the the
the same scattering amplitudes can be
processed in just two or three um terms
that you can write down pen and paper on
a sheet of paper so all of a sudden you
so what they're seeing is space time has
had a good run
but if you force yourself to stick with
space time then the math is ugly you get
hundreds of pages of algebra to compute
scattering amplitudes you can't see the
symmetries that are there like dual
conformal symmetry if you let go
space-time you're finding these amazing
structures that they don't know what
they're about
but all of a sudden you see the right
symmetries and the computations become
trivial
so there's some big hint
that um i think
on a couple fronts from girdle
and from the work by tony kubit and his
team that
the computation is as as powerful as it
is and as much as i love it as a you
know ai person
and a cognitive scientist it it it has
it's always going to be on the seashore
with newton
and
when we let go space-time
we're still of course as theorists
always going to have
a finite set of axioms and and
derivations about you know like the
cosmological polytope and and and so
forth that nema and juan are finding
we're still going to have a finite set
of concepts and derivations so we're not
going to get around girdle's
incompleteness there but at least we're
we're going beyond the notion of time
which is really critical
and
and
and that also cuts at the computational
issues pretty interesting computational
complexity is is about you know a lot of
it's about time complexity
and
what physicists are telling us is that
ultimately
we're gonna have to let go of the notion
of time and so as computer scientists
we're gonna have to rethink complexity
issues when the very notion of time
itself isn't fundamental
so that that's gonna be a real
a real kicker for for us in in computer
science how do we think about complexity
issues when time itself is not the right
way to think about things
and and therefore the sequence of
computations in time is not the right
way to think about things we have some
really deep thinking to do ahead
but
where i i think
we share some common ground yoshi is
i think that a lot of
our experiences and so forth our models
that we built i think that we are
building
internal models
but the question is what is the
apparatus that's building those models
and
i'm saying it's nothing inside space and
time
it so in particular
i'll be very very explicit i i don't
think that neurons exist
when they're not perceived
i don't think space-time exists when
it's not perceived
i think neurons in space-time
and even particles
are are
simply
data structures
that we use
and
there is a a formulation of quantum
theory that that's very similar to this
is called cubism quantum basianism chris
fuchs and david merman
where where they they take this point of
view that it's the
every act of observation
in physics
every experiment that you do is an act
of fact creation
right that that it's not that there are
pre-existing particles with pre-existing
states and you're measuring
those those states
rather the it's their their you know
their subjective bayesians so all the
probabilities in quantum theory are
subjective probabilities they're not
objective probabilities
and every outcome is a
um
a fact creation and they they do have i
mean chris pukes has a very interesting
2010 paper called cubism
um
that i highly recommend and in that
paper he actually points to very
interesting
um
quantum discovery
that there's a sequence of
what what what's proven is that even if
you know what the outcome of your
experiment is going to be with
probability one
that does not entail that the outcome is
there and exists independent of your
observation
that's a stunning thing to say is the
probability one you know with
probability of one what you're going to
measure and yet you can prove
with with quantum mechanics that it's
impossible that the outcome was there
the the value existed before you made
the measurement
so that the it's really the case that
the acts of observation are fact
creations
not
fact discoveries
so
so when we so most of
the work that's done in consciousness
assumes
i would say this is 99 of the theories
that i've seen in consciousness
assume that space-time is fundamental
assume that physical particles are
fundamental and that somehow neural
activity
in humans
and perhaps other kinds of more complex
activity in ais creates creates
consciousness but but the very founding
assumptions that space-time is
fundamental that neurons exist when
they're when they're not perceived
contradicts our best physics and it also
contradicts evolution of natural
selection
which
which is very very clear
natural selection makes it very clear
that the probability is zero
that the sensory systems of any organism
tell them any truths about objective
reality
they tell it what what they tell
organisms sensory systems evolve to tell
organisms how to behave in order to stay
alive period
that's it
and
and so it gives you a user interface
for you know staying alive but but gives
you no access to the truth and that that
fits with what physics is telling us
that that space time is a user interface
but it's not the final truth and so so
what i want from
a theory of consciousness
as a scientist is i want a clear
statement of what are the what am i
assuming
what are the exact things that my theory
takes is primitive
what are the exact rules that
that allow me to drive things from those
primitives and how exactly do i get the
taste of chocolate from that
that's that's what i'm looking for from
from the theory of consciousness precise
statement of exactly what i'm assuming
up front with mathematical precision and
then precise derivation if i'm not
taking the taste of chocolate is
fundamental if i'm saying that somehow
some dynamical system is going to give
it to me then i want to know exactly
which dynamical system is
giving me the taste of chocolate and why
that dynamical system could not be the
smell of garlic i want to know exactly
otherwise there's no there's no real
science on the table
at all so that's what i'm looking for is
theories that say exactly what the
assumptions are and tell me exactly for
at least one specific conscious
experience how that conscious experience
must be
derived in that way and so so that's
where i'm coming from on those now in
the case of of cells and the brain
i i would just mention something that's
very interesting that you probably know
about mike levin's work um
right and and so he's finding that
that
cells not just neurons but but any cell
in in in animals that in fact
outside of the brain
they they can learn
and they can compute
and they can
do morphogenesis of you know of of of
the cell's body they use gap junction
communication electric
so they're effectively um
doing what neurons do but in a very very
different way and and this is all cells
can communicate with in this way with
gap junctions and so forth so i suspect
that
we're going to find that
that
neurons aren't special in in the sense
of being information processors that
that that information processing and
this seems to be where where mike was is
heading um is that that information
processing
is happening in what he calls these
bioelectric fields um even if there are
no neurons and that they can learn they
can retain memories and they can be very
intelligent and so so even as
neuroscientists
we may find that we'll have to expand
our horizons beyond
neuroscience
and understand if if i were a
reductionist and trying to do biological
reduction i would at this point with
mike levin's stuff be be interested to
say oh well maybe i wouldn't necessarily
reduce consciousness to neural activity
maybe these gap junctions and the
computations that cells can do would
also be
a suitable
format but but again i'm not a
reductionist in that sense but i'll stop
unless you respond yeshua
thank you um
you went very far and right and try to
be a little bit more concise
let's start out with good
good spoof had a
very profound and not necessarily very
positive influence on philosophy
and
basically lukasz and others in
philosophy opened up a tradition that
where the underlying current is that
what goodl has shown is that mathematics
is important
to describe reality
and therefore
reality can only be described by people
who don't really know mathematics that
is philosophers
so philosophers like that intuition
right but it implies that there is
something beyond mathematics
that allows you to make sense of things
that assign truth
and uh slightly deeper when you say that
uh you like computation and you value it
and so on and you see its limits it
implies that you see what comes beyond
these limits and you're using that thing
beyond the limits to think
and i don't think that you are
everything in my own mind that i can
observe when i observe myself perceiving
when i perceive myself
reflecting when i perceive myself
reasoning is computational it means that
i go to from state to state
in a somewhat deterministic way the
random parts are just deleting bits that
i computed before so i have to do it
again the randomness and determinism
doesn't help me so the part of my mind
that is relevant to my thinking is
fundamentally computational what girdle
discovered and is often misunderstood
and also by gordo himself
is is a very important thing
what girdle has discovered is not that
truth is deeper than proof
that was in some sense the suspicion
which he started with he knew that
in his view that truth is platonic
that things can be true or not
regardless of whether we find out or
whether it can be found out
and he hoped
to find a notion of truth
of proof that could reach truth
and he found that it couldn't and he
found this in a devastating way
and he drew the conclusion that there is
truth that cannot be found with
mathematics
and the opposite is true
there is no deeper notion of truth than
proof
you see a
perception cannot be true or false
perception just is
physics physical events out there in the
universe cannot be true or false they
just are a pattern that you observe is
not true or false it just is
right you could be erroneously thinking
that you're perceiving a pattern when
you don't because you're suffering from
false memory or a delusion or whatever
that makes your thinking or perception
inconsistent but the pattern itself is
not true or false it's an interpretation
that can be true or false and the
interpretation is has to be in a
symbolic language to have the property
that can be true or false a perceptual
interpretation by itself is not true or
false it just is
right so in order to be true or false
you need to have a language and the
language needs to be defined in such a
way that truths can be established and
the process of establishing truth is a
computation
and there are two types of languages in
which truths can be defined
and the language of classical
mathematics is a stateless language
it's one where time doesn't exist where
everything happens all at once or in
some kind of eternal moment
so if you want to go from state to state
in this language of eternal mathematics
in the stateless language you just
assign an index and then you iterate of
the index and you do this in a single
instant in one moment
and the stateless mathematics has a very
beautiful property it allows you to deal
with infinities because you can now
construct functions that take infinitely
many arguments in a single step
perform an operation over them in a
single step and give the result back in
a single step
it's a language in which you can assign
a value to pi
right in the computational system you
cannot really assign a value to pi you
can have a function that gives you
digits by digit but you never get to the
latest last digit it also means that
digit can uh pi can never be written
down in such a way that you can have a
process that relies on knowing all the
digits of pi and consumes them to tune
the outcome of some physical process
right if you
make the switch to a stateful language
in which you can only go from step to
step
you're losing certain things you're
losing the ability to treat pi as a
value pi is now certainly a function
that you can only approximate to a
certain degree
and many other things stop being values
you'll get a fundamental difference
between a value of the function a value
is something that you have already
computed that you know how to compute by
extension
and this means that also that truth
changes truth is no longer this platonic
thing that precedes mathematics and
where we can use mathematics as a tool
to figure it out
it has to be contingent on the language
in which you use it
if your language has internal
contradictions
then truth becomes impossible to
determine
right
you get into areas in this language
where it falls apart you can no longer
use it to express coherent thoughts
about reality and korean models about
reality
you can never make statements in the
language that you can prove outside of
the language so you cannot use your
language to prove things that are not
cannot be described in the language
your only hope to prove statements about
the universe that you exist in inner
language is that you are able to
recreate the observations that you make
inside of the language which means you
recreate a model of the universe that is
so good
that it gives you what you observe
correctly and then you can hope that the
statements that you make in your
language capture something about the
reality
outside of you that gives rise to your
observations but of course you cannot
know because it could also be different
but if your language is not able to
produce what's on your screen
then your language is wrong
and hilbert basically gave out this task
to mathematicians to find a machine
any kind of structural sound language
that is able to run the semantics of
mathematics without breaking and what
goethe discovered is that the semantics
of stateless mathematics cannot be
recovered if you assume that there is a
solution to get stateless mathematics to
work
you will run into contradictions
of the way that google is covered
but there is a way out
you just
drop the notion of truth that is
independent of the sequence of
operations the number of the set of
steps that you took the algorithm that
you took
to get to your result
it means that when you have a
self-referential statement like this
sentence is false
right this is a sentence that of the
type that god has shown leads and for
contradictions if you assume that there
is a stable notion of truth
that is stateless
if you accept that truth is not
necessarily a stable value and you look
at the sentence then as long as you look
at it
the truth value will fluctuate
because the assumption that the sentence
is true will lead to the sentence being
false and vice versa so suddenly you
have no longer a stable truth predicate
and it just means that the property of
the languages in which you can actually
deal with truth and assign it is that
under some circumstances the truth
predicate will not be stable
and it's fine there's nothing wrong with
that
and uh this same thing applies to the
entities problem that um
turing was dealing with when it came to
the halting problem we defined
originally the turing machine in such a
way that we could translate stateless
mathematics
into algorithms
and this might require that you have to
go through an infinite sequence of steps
and if you make this assumption that you
sometimes in order to get to truth you
have to go to an infinite sequence of
steps
you run into contradictions
so you might use an unbounded sequence
of steps that gives you continuously
results that's fine
but you cannot accept that anything
exists in any kind of universe that has
caused a structure
that is going to produce your solution
to the heartache problem that is which
would give you back stateless
mathematics
so basically what good and turing have
shown is
that stateless mathematics doesn't work
and when we look back at the history of
mathematics mathematicians have never
used stateless mathematics they only
pretended to whenever they actually
wanted to compute something with
mathematics they under the hood use
stateful descriptions they never took in
infinitely many arguments and performed
infinitely many
operations on them and the intuition
that stateless mathematics makes sense
is because we had this intuition that
continuity that space and time in a
continuous fashion exist
why do we have this information well
that's pretty easy to answer right the
number of things that we interact with
if we zoom in we find that they are
discrete although observations have a
discrete resolution in time and in space
all our knowledge that we store about
these
observables is has a discrete
number of bits that we can assign to
them
there is only finite number of
information that we can access and that
we can deal with as an observer that is
embedded in this universe so everything
was discrete to begin with but it's too
many parts to count
if you deal with too many parts to count
the inside that number of atoms that you
are in an ocean is a finite bounded
number it doesn't help you at all
because it's still almost infinite from
the perspective of an observer so when
you want to describe what the ocean is
doing it doesn't help to count the
molecules in it and to assign locations
to them and uh what are the interactions
doesn't work there is too much
so when you look at the dynamics too of
too many parts to count you're looking
for operations that converge in the
limit which means they behave quite
similar whether you're using a trillion
or 10 trillion or gazillion particles
right once you have these operators that
give you the same dynamics under all
circumstances when you take more and
more elements to them this this this
part of mathematics that describes the
convergent operators
that's geometry
and some of geometry is uncomputable so
you can only approximate it
but our brain has discovered geometry to
deal with the world of too many parts to
count
and this plays into what you are
pointing out when you say that
our perception doesn't give us reality
it gives us something that we can work
with
of course the reality that we are
embedded in has too many parts to count
we need a different reality we need one
that you can actually handle even if
it's not computable it can only be
approximated
and this experimental reality is a very
coarse simplification it's about as
coarse as a gaming engine is when you
play computer game as compared to real
physics
it's not much better than that in many
ways it's even worse which you can
verify if you put yourself into a lucid
dream and look at the fidelity of what
your brain is able to generate light
switches will usually not work you will
not be able to read the same stuff twice
on the same page and you imagine it and
so on there's only so many bits in your
working memory the fidelity of what your
perceptual system can track and imagine
is limited
it's relatively easy to overcome that
don't really know what the number of
bits in my working memory is and that
would be very curious to find out
but
it's not as big as i thought when i was
a child it's not infinite it's not
unlimited perception of infinity is
super easy to generate when your mind is
very finite super easy to overwhelm my
finite resolution mind
so
this deep thing that good is
misunderstood that google has not
discovered that mathematics cannot reach
truth but that truth is no more than the
result of a sequence of steps that is
compressing a statement to axioms
losslessly and doesn't go beyond that
that was the deep insight and it's one
that basically has not percolated in
most areas of philosophy and even
physics yet because the physicists have
checked out the code base for
mathematics before that result was
obtained and understood so basically
that we need to switch from continuous
stateless mathematics to constructive
mathematics that was not understood back
then
and it needs to be understood now
so uh basically my
uh question to uh somebody like donald
would not be so much how to explain the
spectral gap room because i think
problems of this case of this type are
with the result of using continuous
notions of space-time
and infinities
and assuming them as given so it's a
statement about certain theories that
are
expressed in the language that has
inconsistencies in this language with
these inconsistencies you get to the
point that you cannot get certain
results there's also an issue of
computational irreducibility which is
difficult to understand in stateless
mathematics computational irreducibility
is a property of a system
that means that you cannot obtain the
state of the system
without running the system to that point
there is no way to predict the system
except by taking the system with all its
detail and fidelity
and going through the sequence of steps
so you cannot predict what the universe
is going to do when the universe is
computationally reusable you're going to
predict some things but not all of
things and these some things only with a
certain degree of certainty because you
can
often not insulate them from the parts
that you cannot predict because they are
computationally irreducible
in a universe that is played out and
implemented in a stateless language that
is a confusing property
because the cost of computation doesn't
play a role when you are in a stateless
universe in a stateful universe the
number of state transitions that your
model needs to make plays a suddenly a
certain role and
this
specter of computational irreducibly uh
dooms large it means that you cannot
compute things for practical reasons
because you don't have enough
information yet and you cannot have
information to make that prediction but
there is no deep miracle uh that is not
caused by the language when you discover
that the spectral gap problem is uh
incomputable so my question to donald
would be if you think that there is a
limit to computation that you can see
and previously
you would still do something and make
statements what is it that you use to
make statements beyond the limits of
computation
what parts of uh of your mind are you
drawing from when you make statements
beyond what a computational system can
derive
right so
so well one way of
trying to focus this would be to
talk about the integers versus the real
numbers
and and the rational numbers
so
from your point of view yosha is it um
do you think that
so so for example if we
look at just the set of all functions
from the integers to the integers right
it's trivial to show that that's not
countable
so
yeah touring showed that the set of
computable functions is countable the
set of turing machines is countable
so
so in that simple example just to make
things very very concrete
the the set of all functions from the
integers to the integers isn't countable
the turing computable functions are
countable and so there's a sense in
which the turing computable functions
have measure zero
they have their probability zero on the
set of all of all functions
so do we want to conclude
from from this computationalist point of
view that
that all those other functions don't
exist with that that we're sort of
when i so you you're saying those
functions so so real numbers don't exist
real numbers
yes for something to exist it has to uh
be implemented
if it's something it's not implemented
anywhere it doesn't make sense to claim
that it exists i think it's a confusion
of the notion of existence to say that
something that is not implemented and is
not implementable could exist
the things that produce patterns that we
observe in order to exist and need to be
implemented right
so uh you could say does the financial
system exist well it exists to the
degree that it's implemented there are
some boundaries very projected and it's
not actually implemented where it
doesn't actually exist only in some
course approximation but by and large
something exists right some causal
structure is implemented here the set of
all the functions between the integers
is not implementable therefore it
doesn't exist
it's something that you can specify and
this difference between specification
and existence is something that is very
obvious to a computer scientist
and sometimes not obvious to a
traditional mathematician
there is stuff that you can specify that
makes no sense it is only specifiable in
your language but that's because your
language is much more permissible than
the set of things that can be uh can
exist and computation is less
permissible computation only permits you
to build things that can actually exist
if you can build things that cannot
exist it's a problem of your language in
which you're building things it's not a
problem of reality just confused
i have a comment this one's from
professor edward lee of berkeley and it
may provide some insight and you both
can tell us your thoughts on this so
this is from professor edward lee of
berkeley this question is a major theme
in the second half of my book plato and
the nerd utms so universal turing
machines have the following properties
number one their operation is a sequence
of discrete steps number two the data
comes from a countable set number three
that sequence terminates it is a huge
leap of faith to assume that physical
processes have any of these constraints
i show in plato and the nerd that the
hypothesis that physical processes all
have these properties is actually
untestable i remember earlier yosha you
mentioned that
if it's untestable and you can't provide
evidence for it then perhaps it
shouldn't be talked about so this
reminded me of this and he says in
brackets this follows from an
information theorem due to clochen and
known as the channel capacity theorem
the converse hypothesis that the
physical world is not so constrained is
also untestable by experiment but i
argue in plato and the nerd that the
converse hypothesis leads to simpler
models of the universe and therefore is
a better choice by outcomes razor my
claim is that universal turing machines
is realized on today's computers are
simulations quote-unquote of a process
that is fundamentally non-algorithmic so
i just want to place that out there and
perhaps you can use that as a jumping
off board donald and then yosha
very interesting i'll want to to read
that book and make sure i understand
what uh professor lee is saying that's
quite interesting so plato and the nerd
um
i'll be interviewing edward at some
point in the next few weeks as well
oh oh very good yeah that's that's
that's really quick because these are
very very
deep issues it seems to me that this
also interacts with what the physicists
are telling us that there is
no time fundamentally
so so if if time is not fundamental then
these computational issues where there
are
fundamental limits to what can be
computed because we're assuming time
a sequence of so in in computer
simulations computer algorithms
we're assuming
a sequence in time of computations that
can be and the kinds of limits that
yoshi's talking about
seems to me um
are a consequence of assuming time to be
fundamental and if we have to go to a
physics in which time is not fundamental
then that that places this whole our
whole conversation in a completely
different context
and and and so
what we may be pointing to is
time has
been a very useful and helpful thing for
physics for several centuries and and
now the hard work that we have to do is
to understand
how to go beyond the notion of time and
when we go beyond the notion of time
well the kind of the discussion we're
having
right now we fundamentally revised um
the computational versus
non-computational notions we may have to
really
revise how our whole conversation here
is going i'd be very interested what
yoshi has to say on that
thank you also thanks edward lee for
your
argument
i
uh concur with you that it's in
principle not testable what physics is
really like
what we can only say is which theory
that we can come up with is more elegant
but uh i
as a small thing i i think that this
notion that the turing machine has to
get a result after a finite sequence of
steps
may be a mistake in the sense in which
two machines were originally defined
so basically a computer that can be
built is not a turing machine in this
sense but
it's always a finite state machine
and in a finite state machine you can
have a number of steps uh sequence of
steps that is unbounded that doesn't
stop and that gives you more and more
digits of pi while you're looking at in
a sense it doesn't come to a conclusion
if you want to compute physics but it's
not the problem to build a computer that
as long as it runs gives you more digits
of pi
and so i think from a formal perspective
or from an uh it doesn't make much of a
difference because you can easily fix it
but it's important
if you think about your intuitions about
how things work or the proofs that you
make in other contexts that the value of
computation doesn't hinge on there being
a finite number of steps until a
computation that is going to give you a
result that was formulated classical
mathematics terminates but that it means
that everything that you get is the
result of finite interactions
and if you assume that infinite
interactions are possible you run into
the difficulties that girdle and turing
has have discovered which means that
your theories no longer work they no
longer make sense
and uh different from edward and maybe
doing him in justice here i haven't read
this book um
so
i would say that it's much more elegant
from the perspective how comes razer to
describe reality in a language that
doesn't break
because if your language breaks and you
still try to make a
model of reality it's going to be
arbitrarily expensive it doesn't work
you have to find a language that works
so if we find that the languages in
which we can describe reality have to be
computational languages because the
others lead into contradictions then we
have to use the computational languages
that's the situation that i find myself
to be in this doesn't mean that i can
know what physics is like it just means
that all the physics that i can talk
about without my language breaking
has to play out in this way
and the notion of what is time so coming
back to donald is uh is very important
that there are two notions of time one
is this intuitive notion that we have as
human beings which is
basically this newtonian time this uh
time which uh
where clocks run the same speed
everywhere and so on and that describes
the transition of the universe from the
past into the future via the present
and
this notion of time is somewhat similar
to the notion of the straight state
transition in your computer
except that the state transition in a
computer has some kind of global clock
where everything in the computer goes
from state to state all at once and goes
progresses to the next step but what we
see in our universe that it only makes
sense if we assume that it's dynamic
if the universe would just be a
decoupled sequence of states without a
transition function there would not be
any law that we can discover there is
nothing that we can control organisms
would not exist in the way in which they
do so the
from the observations that we make we
have to assume that the transitions in
the universe are somehow fundamental
that the universe is moving
and state transitions seem to be crucial
in order to be able to understand the
universe that there is some notion of
transition and this notion of transition
is much more basic than time
and
the time that we are talking about when
we see that time is not fundamental in
the notion of space-time is relativistic
time
the relativistic time is what the
universe looks like to a relativistic
observer
and we can obtain relativistic time if
we understand that
what we perceive as time is basically
the speed of the clocks in our
environment
and the speed of the clocks that we
observe depend on our own speed
so if i move you through the universe
and you are a supervision pattern on the
structure of the universe imagine the
universe is something like an ocean
and the present is the crest of a
traveling wave through that ocean
and
there are
waves maybe in front and behind us but
they're not our future the past they're
different universes that just happen to
be a little more along a bit less along
the future and past would require you to
leave the crest of the wave and you
can't because you're always traveling
with the wave
so there is no way to leave that present
because only the present exists from the
perspective of that crest and you or me
we are vortices and scraped
on the crest of that traveling wave
and the
rotation that the vortex is doing when
it updates itself to observe the
universe to form a memory and so on and
to register its perceptions and so on
will depend on the speed in which this
vortex rotates
right
and so if the vortex is moving along
with the wave then the updates in the
vortex are a function of the movement in
the wave itself the basic parasitize on
the movement of the main wave
and you can not as this vortex traveling
with the wave ever leave the wave you
can move a little bit in this in the
wave to the left or to the right
that is moving to the left or the right
would be movement in space you cannot
move in time you just move this the time
right and the faster you move to the
left or to the right the less there will
be updates available for in turning your
internal state
so the fluctuations of the vortex
becomes
slower and slower the more the vortex
moves in space and this leads to
relativistic time it means that from the
perspective
of the vortex when it looks at its
environment the environment gets
distorted in time and space
so in this notion we realize why
something would look like to a vertex
that moves like this
like relativistic time and we understand
that the relativistic time from the
fundamental perspective how to make all
this happening how to build a system
that functions like this cannot be
fundamental
it's a result to the observer it will be
what the universe looks like to the
observer of the observer screens as we
always do
right but it is not fundamental but
fundamental are the state transitions
so what we need to do is basically
replace the physical this time that is
relativistic for good reason in the
frame of certain models by something
that is more fundamental and allows us
to derive the relativistic time and this
would be state transitions
very very interesting there's some
in that spirit um or at least in that
kind of direction there's
work by marcus mueller and and philip
hone
and and then also some some more recent
work um
by fabio mercadi and um
and giovanni
emelina camilla
where where they're
showing how relativistic space times can
be
constructed
from exchange of quantum information so
you don't assume it up front but you try
to get a dictionary
to that allows
different uh
quantum
agents to send information back and
forth and it turns out if you send
enough information back and forth
and try to set up a dictionary to make
everything consistent you will get
einstein's
special relativistic um space time
coming out of it so that's that that's
that's
an interesting direction
to go
um another
interesting direction
to think about one just a simple notion
time and entropy are
at least physical time and entropy are
are deeply connected
and so we would like to have some way of
getting entropic time coming out of
a deeper system in which there is no
entropic time right
and there is a
i'm not saying this is the deepest way
of doing it but an interesting simple
way just in the case of markovian
dynamics so if i have a
a markovian system
um
homogeneous
and it's in a stationary
then the entropy of that system doesn't
change so
if if for state x sub n and x n minus 1
and so forth the entropy h of x of n
equals h of x sub n minus 1 for all n
so you so there is no entropic time
but
it's trivial to prove
that if you just do a simple
conditioning if i if i look at
xn given x1
or x yeah x n given but then it turns
out
that
h of x n
given x one is greater than or equal to
h of x n given x n minus one
in other words
the very fact of and
doing conditioning which is projection
so you can think about
i take this
dynamical system
which has a notion of state transition
it's a markov chain
but it doesn't have any entropic time
but as soon as you start projecting that
that non-entropic system onto different
perspectives by
by conditioning like h of x n given x
one all of a sudden now you have entropy
and so now you have that kind of notion
of time so so is that a direction that
we could go
where where we could still have
in some sense a dynamical system but
it's not an entropic time system
and and show how we get space time
arising from that in in the way that you
know that some of these businesses are
trying to do i i think that will be
be interesting i think that it's a
separate question whether the real
numbers exist versus right that's
it's a it's a pretty strong statement to
say that real numbers don't exist that's
that's really quite interesting
to say that they don't exist
but i guess that that's where you want
to go anyway
yeah well i agree with categorized that
real numbers don't exist and the time
was not right back then so real numbers
are actually functions
and you can
can give you this function instead of a
real number and it can give you as many
digits as you want or as you can afford
to compute but this is it it's fine
so basically real numbers uh can be
derived in a deterministic fashion they
are determined once uh they are
predetermined in the sense
but uh you will not know the billions
digit of
the square root of two unless you find a
procedure to compute it and uh the
energy
for the neck entropy
to
actually get there
and this derivation of
a result via using upnic entropy i think
relates to our perception of time this
causal error of time which is aligned
with the entropic arrow
eric thresher finds a very good metaphor
in his book good and real i think to
give an intuition how a symmetric system
um
where the transitions are symmetric in
both directions
is still
not going to be
symmetric at scale when you look at it
so it digs as an example a well that is
made of large and small billiard balls
and did you put one of these billiard
balls in motion and uh the transaction
between the little balls are also
magical which means if you take a movie
and you play it forward and backward
you will see for the every interaction
between two billiard balls that it's the
same if you go the movie backwards or
forwards it's a simplified model where
you have no friction and so we have no
thermodynamic uh stuff going on we look
at the universe at the level where
thermodynamics doesn't exist yet because
this maybe the staff is too small to
have these losses right so we just look
at the billiard ball universe where
everything is deterministic and without
noise and in this model what we see is
that when we zoom out there is something
that is happening
at scale and that is
some
balls move after they have been hit and
keep moving hitting other balls
and there are if you play the movie
backwards it looks as if some balls are
anticipating that they are going to be
soon hit and start moving
as a result as if they would be hit
right so there is this asymmetry that uh
your balls leave a wake
behind them
and this vague
is describing in some sense the entropy
that we are looking at in our universe
that's the direction in which you can as
an embedded observer for memories
because in order to form memories you
rely on the dissipation of information
between locations
and so whenever
there is a way to form memories it means
that you are aligned with some kind of
entropic arrow
if you zoom out it means that you can
now sort the states of the universe in
such a way that you discover the
concentric wave that you are that you
are part of in our
ocean-like universe
has a point of origin
and this point of origin is a
construction that you make you discover
this by the wave expanding and you
discover it by information
moving diffusing across the locations in
the wave so there is a hypothetical
point
in the middle
where the information is not diffused
yet
and this hypothetical point is what we
imagine to be the big bang
right and it's a mathematical
singularity in a way because if you are
in the big bank you don't know which
direction to go unless the big bang is
not completely perfect and symmetrical
and the interesting thing about this
before the big bang means uh it's it's
the wrong question to ask because before
the big bang if you it looked like it is
like a more rape pattern
this would be the point where the
information goes out of a distribution
or gets distributed or diffuses between
locations in the other direction every
point of every trajectory that goes away
from the big bang goes into a future
sorry to interrupt is this related to
the janus point
have you heard of julian barber's theory
of time
no
no but it's a it's an artifact of a
certain description basically we create
a certain mental model in which we
describe the
entropic era of time as the diffusion of
information across locations in the
universe and then we imagine that there
is a single point where this ends up and
we go through this point on the other
side we go back into another future
so so the further we go away from this
point in any direction the further we go
into a future in which systems could
form memories of the past and to form
memories of the past you need to have
some kind of reservoir of neck entropy
that you can tap and some kind of puddle
of neck entropy and then you can reason
about the conditions uh how such puddles
of neck entropy could form under which
conditions and how long they might last
i would like to get to the topic of free
will as well and then also some audience
questions so why don't you donald
outline your views on free will
okay uh
yeah
if
in a physicalist framework
which i so now i'll just talk about what
most of my
cognitive neuroscience peers think right
most of them assume that that physical
systems are fundamental
neural activity causes
um all of our behavior
and
in in that case um
there can be a a fiction of
a useful fiction of of free will but but
it's really just going to be a useful
fiction if i do something it's really my
neurons with the neural activity
that that did it and
um there is a sense in which you can say
i chose to do it because actually
neurons are part of me so i
i think that's the point of view that
dan dennett takes for example on this
and
and
and and sam harris you know replies on
that he says well yeah i also grill my
fingernails i'm not sure that i'm doing
that by free will but you know what
so so it's not real clear that just
because my neurons are doing it i have
free will just in the same sense that i
don't i'm not using free will to grow my
my my fingernails
um
so
so sam would say there's no such thing
as as free will if you're a physicist
dan dennett would say i'm a physicist
and there is this important notion of
free will
um
i i think that of course space time
isn't fundamental and so that we have to
completely think outside of that box all
together
and
as as scientists we have to
say up front what our hypotheses what
our axioms or
fundamental assumptions are
and and be very clear about them up
front
these conscious agents
in the mathematics they they get
certain inputs we call them experiences
that they have
and then they they there's a something
called a markovian kernel that that
describes what actions they take and
those actions affect the experiences of
other conscious agents
so so then there's so that's just the
mathematics that that my team has
written down it's a very simple notion
of markovian dynamics of conscious
agents interacting
and and it's not in the physical
framework
we're assuming that this is
you know in its own world right these
are conscious agents
and and that's the foundation space and
time are not the foundation conscious
agents so conscious experiences and
interactions of conscious agents are the
foundational notion
and
so then the question is how shall we
understand
the probabilities so if i get a
particular experience that
comes into a conscious agent
and it then
probabilistically affects the experience
of other agents how shall i
understand that probability
that it
shall i understand it as as a free will
choice
or or what um
and
you know i could say you know i refuse
to answer the question i just there's a
probability there and that's that's as
far as i go with with the theory there's
you know this agent
so i leave that probability as just um
where my theory stops right i say
in some sense wherever we see a
probability in a theory that's where
explanation stops
right
that's that's basically saying
i don't know like my so whenever so i
said is whenever in a scientific theory
you see probabilities coming up
um
you're seeing the theory say this is
where i halt
uh this is where my explanation stops
and there are two major
approaches toward understanding those
probabilities the objectivist and
subjectivist
to probabilities right so
objectivists say that these
probabilities are
pointing to some real
thing in the world there is some real
random generator in the world
um
and
subjectivists say no um
these are just degrees of beliefs
whenever you see probabilities
you're only talking about
degrees of belief
um but
in either case
explanation stops right
how do i come to that belief well i can
only tell you probabilities
what is that random objective process i
don't know but i can just tell you um
probabilities and so so really whenever
you see probabilities in the scientific
theory and they're all over the place
i read that as saying here's where
explanation stops um and our theories
our theories halt um and and if we want
to go further we're gonna have to unpack
that probability into some some deeper
deeper theory
so
if i say that it's
free will
in case of the conscious agents
um then i mean
in some sense that's just words
what what the theory has is the
probabilities and it has no further
explanation so if i say if i call that
probability of a free will
then i you know i can call it that but
but i haven't really done much to
give much insight into the notion of
free will free will then becomes a
primitive and and maybe that's what i
want to do i want to say um this is
where explanation stops and so free will
is primitive so when these probabilities
are our free will and i agree to that
that that's where my theory stops that i
i can do no further
um
now what's interesting in the in the the
conscious agent dynamics that we're
working on is that um
any group of conscious agents
together also satisfy the definition of
a conscious agent and so they are a
conscious agent so any conscious agents
interacting are also conscious agents so
they're in the third there's one
conscious agent
because if you take all of them together
they form one conscious agent but then
there are as many
um if you're computational there's only
accountable number of them or in my case
i don't know if it may be an uncountable
number of of conscious
agents but what's interesting is that
the you unpack this probability in the
markovian kernel there could be one big
probability for the one agent
but you can unpack that into all these
dynamical systems interacting conscious
agents with their own probabilities in
their own kernels and what's what's
interesting is that you could then
give in some sense an unpacking of the
notion of free will in that way you
could say well yeah the the one agent
has free will in this this probability
but i can actually
do some non-trivial unpacking of that
notion in this sort of recursive
unwinding of those probabilities um
throughout the network so so
there is the possibility here
of i mean ultimately
um
there will be a primitive notion of free
will that that is just primitive and not
explained but given that one i can
explain all these other free wills sort
of interacting
arising from this most primitive notion
of free will in a non-trivial
non-trivial way but but once again i i
would i would point out
something that i see all the time in
scientific theories no theory in science
will ever explain everything
and and and i would love to see if josh
joshua
agrees disagrees i i will just state to
make a strong claim
um
there cannot be a theory of everything
because every theory has to make
assumptions and those assumptions
are not explained they're assumed
it's just that simple
okay am i correct in my
summary of your views on free will that
if in a physical theory you have
probability now some of that probability
is just due to our ignorance but if
there's a fundamental probability you
can just say well that's indicating that
the theories break down we just don't
know or you can say that there's
something underneath producing those and
that which is underneath the
probabilities is what you're calling
free will is that correct or is that off
right so if i'm a physicalist i'll say
that that probability is due to some
process that i can say no more about but
there's some process that generates this
stuff it's not free will it's just a
physical process that that um i don't
know but if i'm taking consciousness to
be fundamental then it's an interesting
move to say that that that free that
that probability um can be interpreted
as
free will now of course i'm not
explaining anything i'm not you mean
i'm just putting the frame for the
notion free will the word free will on
it right
and and and free will becomes just a
a primitive notion as well i'm so that's
where my explanation stops and i'm the
most unpacking i can do is that
recursive unpacking that i that i
mentioned which is an interesting
unpacking but ultimately there's this
primitive notion of free will that i
have nothing further to say about but
but i think that um
that's not
a problem specific to this theory i the
last thing i was saying was that that's
endemic to all scientific theories every
scientific theory will have miracles at
its foundation by miracles i mean
assumptions that are taken for granted
and not explained
if you explain them then you'll have a
deeper theory with new assumptions that
explain those assumptions but the new
assumptions aren't explained and so so
in this sense
science can never have a theory of
everything because science
theories always have assumptions and the
assumptions are what you don't explain
yosha i know donald said quite a few
there are quite a few elements to pick
from there
three um
interlocking claims but let's address
them um
first of all i don't know whether there
can be a
one theory of everything
because my reasoning is not tight enough
to have to make that proof one way or
the other
so at this point i have to remain
agnostic because i think from where i
stand it seems to be possible that there
can be a theory of everything and it
seems to be possible that they cannot
from a computational list perspective
whenever you have a set of observations
that is
finite you will be able to construct a
computational model that explains how to
make such patterns
so in principle there can always be a
theory of everything that you observe
that's something that i cannot
they don't see a way around this so this
seems to be sound to me and i think that
can be formally proven
but uh
and it seems to be almost trivial that
it's too proven so it's more interesting
the question is can you narrow this down
to a single one to one theory of
everything
right you will be always stuck with
infinitely many theories of everything
where most of these theories will be
super inelegant and uh redundant and
basically recordings of your
observations or
will there be one theory that is the
most elegant and explains everything
deeply and wraps it up and of course if
you think about the space of all
theories and think of them as things
that you can do in a language and
in which you can define truth and if you
realize that the languages in which you
can define truth consistently these are
the computational languages it turns out
that all your models are going to be
automata and that you can sort the space
of automata by the length of the
definitions so it also seems that in
principle it should be possible to find
the shortest automaton between two every
pair of automata that you can construct
and connect with now the question is
what's your search procedure for all the
possible automata do you have a search
procedure that you can hope that
terminates
and this is uh not a question of whether
it's mathematically uh possible uh but
whether it's efficient so you do is
there an efficient
strategy to find the theory of
everything that is the shortest one
and so far we haven't found one
and it relates to
what ai is doing in machine learning
when it tries to identify what's going
on in the domain
so while in principle we can always be
sure that we could be a brain in a vet
and everything is just a nefarious
conspiracy
that is playing out and because we
cannot exclude this we can never be sure
that our theory of everything is uh
is the best theory that could exist
of things so that's obviously the case
but if we uh take out this single thing
and make the assumption that reality is
not a conspiracy
uh i think then it look starts to look a
lot brighter
let's get to the notion of free will
i think that free will is tied into the
notion of agency
and the best
explanation of what an agent is that i
found so far is that an agent is a
control system
that is intrinsically combined with its
own set point generator a control system
is a notion from cybernetics it means
you have some system like a thermostat
that is making a measurement using
sensors for instance the temperature in
the room and that has a factors by which
it can change the dynamics of the system
so the effector would be a switch that
turns the heating on and off and the
system that's being regulated is the
temperature in the room and the
temperature in the room is disturbed by
the environment
and a simple thermostat will only act on
its present measurement and then
translate this present measurement using
a single parameter into whether it
should switch or not and depending on
choosing that
parameter well you have a more efficient
regulation or not
but if you want to be more efficient you
need to model the environment and the
dynamics of the system
and maybe the dynamics of the sensory
system and the actuator itself
and you can do this it means that you
model the future of the regulation
based on past observations so if you
endow the controller with the ability to
make a model of the future and use this
control model to fine-tune the actions
of the controller
it means that this a controller now is
more than a thermostat it's not going to
just optimize the temperature in the
room in the next frame but it's going to
optimize the integral of the temperature
over a long time span so it basically
takes a long expectation horizon the
fast further it goes the better probably
and then it tries to minimize all the
temperature deviations from the ideal
temperature from the set point over that
time span and this means that depending
on the fidelity and detail of the model
of its environment and its interaction
with the environment and itself
it's going to be better and better if it
assumes that there are trajectories in
the world that are the result of its own
decisions
right by turning the temperature on and
off at this particular point in time i'm
going to get this in this result
depending on the weather outside
depending on how often people uh open
and close the door to the room at
different times of the day depending on
the aging of my sensor or the
distance of my sensor to the heating and
depending on whether the
window and on top of the sensor is
currently open or closed and so on i get
lots and more more ways to differentiate
the event flow in the universe and the
path that the universe can take and the
interactions uh that that i can have
with the universe that determine whether
somebody will open the window and so on
and so on right so you uh have all these
uh points where the controller is a very
differentiated model of reality where
it's going to prefer some events of
others and is going to
assign its own decisions to these
trajectories
and this decision making necessarily
happens under conditions of uncertainty
which means the controller will never be
completely sure which one is going to
the right decision the controller will
have to make educated guesses bets on
the future
and this even includes the models of
itself right the better the control
system understands itself and the
limitations of its modeling ability the
better its models are going to be so at
some point of complexity this thing is
going to understand its own modeling
procedure to improve it and to find gaps
in it and so on
and
this also means that when it starts to
do this it is going to discover that
there are agents in the world other
controllers that have set points
generators and model the future and make
decisions for instance people that might
open the window when you make the room
too hard and you lose energy because of
that right so maybe not overheat the
room when people are in the room uh
right this this means you have to model
agency at some point and you will also
discover yourself as an agent in the
world as a controller as a set point
generator and the ability to model the
future
and you will discover this before you
understand how your own modeling of the
future works
right so you also have to make bets on
how you work
before you understand yourself
right so you will discover a self model
the self model is the agent
where the contents of your own model are
driving the behavior of that agent
and it's a very particular agent it's
one where your reasoning and your
modeling has an influence on what this
agent is going to do a direct coupling
it's a very specific model a very
specific agent that you discover there
and so in some sense free will i think
is a perspective on decision making
under uncertainty
starting from the point where you
discover your own self model
up to the point where you deconstruct it
again and of course you will deconstruct
it again at some point you will be able
to fully understand how you are
operating
and once you do this
making your decision becomes
indistinguishable from predicting your
decision
and because of computational
irreducibility often you will not be
able to predict the position before you
make it right
but uh
as soon as you understand that there's
just a computational process going on
and you are understand the properties of
that process you will no longer
experience yourself as having free will
free will is a particular kind of model
that happens as a result of your own
self model being a simulacrum instead of
being a high fidelity simulation of how
you actually work
and we are young beings we don't get
very old it's very difficult for us to
get to the point where we fully
understand how we work
except in certain circumstances right
when we observe our children very often
we get to the point as parents that we
fully understand what they will be doing
in a given situation we can fully
understand their own actions and
anticipate their decisions and the child
might experience that it has free will
and we experience that the child has
revealed up to the point where we
suddenly understand oh this is what's
going on
and at this point i can completely
control the child because he can out
model it
right and it's only to the point where
this system is going to introduce levels
that are again reaching my own level
that decisions become unpredictable but
if i am a few levels of modelling depth
above the other agent that might think
that it is prevail the free will start
to disappear from my own perspective and
also happens in my own mind as many
things that i do but i thought as a
child i'm acting out of my own free will
and now i understand how mechanical it
is and i can deal with myself
by controlling myself by outmodeling
myself successively and becoming one
more complex in this way
and and all that yoshi the um the
computational process the probabilities
in the transition rules you would view
those as objective probabilities then
yes so there is also this issue that i
don't actually exist in the way in which
i model myself i only exist to some
degree of approximation i'm not this big
tree that is strictly implemented in
physical reality i'm more like a bunch
of shrubbery
and some of the shrubbery is tasked with
making a model of myself as a tree
and that model is going to be a course
approximation so the fact that i am
unable to follow up on my plans means
that i'm only approximately implemented
right the rubber hand illusion is a good
example of how we're continually
redefining who we are right where you
tap and drag on the hand at the same
time you're
tapping and dragging on a rubber hand
and
if you do it just right with the person
they'll take this rubber hand and
incorporate it into their body image so
we're always learning who we are
but those probabilities in that learning
process you would take as objective
probabilities and not free will kinds of
probabilities
and what does it mean that a probability
is objective it only means based on the
models in which which i have currently
made and if i go
far beyond back i
cannot assign an objective probability
to the probabilities that i am observing
because they are contingent on the
assumption for instance i'm currently
not in a dream
or that my memories are correct or that
my data are correct or that my the
theories that event and to establish the
relationships between my measurements
and my data and so on are correct so uh
i do agree that at some point there are
a lot of assumptions go into this and
these assumptions
differ with you are usually mild
because i make so many observations that
at some point i can the
errors cancel each other out or there's
so many people that can verify my ideas
and shut them down and so my ideas don't
exist in isolation they are being shot
against every philosophy and physics
book that i can get my hands on and that
i understand right and every
conversation that i have so
that doesn't mean that uh i will
discover the truth in this way but it
means that i discover many many of the
possible errors that i can make and at
some point i realized that there is a
finite space of theories that exists
and uh that we are discovering the same
things again and again so when we ask
ourselves what are integers for instance
or what are rational numbers
there are many ways of making theories
about what integers are for instance we
can say that there are the cardinalities
of sets or so basically you count
members of a set and this is an integer
and all the numbers of members of sets
that you can have are integers
or you can say that they are a
subsequent labeling scheme that's the
definition that i currently prefer
or you can use pianos axioms to
formalize them
and it turns out that they all describe
exactly the same thing
there are all different perspectives on
the same thing and once you understand
the larger space that arounds the
integers you also understand why there
are different perspectives because you
understand how these perspectives are
being constructed and you can show that
it's all the same thing and this so in
some sense the integers are a fractal
and you can describe this fractal using
a generator function and you can also
describe it in many other ways
and it seems that mathematics or all the
languages that you can use that work are
usually a small relatively
intelligible set of fractals
and they are the boundary of what is
intelligible to the human mind
but not that far above it and probably
still inside of it
so i'm more optimistic than you are
i have a question for the both of you
it's about your models how much of it
would have to change let's say yosha in
your case if classical logic was indeed
correct if continuities exist and for
donald if the opposite was true so
continuity doesn't exist intuitionist
logic is
primary
so
at some point in my life i thought that
continuity must exist because everybody
was assuming that they did like most of
the eminent physicists thought that the
universe must be fundamentally
continuous many of the foundational
theories that we have in physics assume
that there is continuity and i thought
that my inability to derive continuity
to construct a continuous system
is the result of my lack of
understanding
and it took me quite some time to
realize that
what godel has stumbled upon
was actually the inside that continuity
cannot exist because it's not
constructive cannot be implemented
so once you have the infinities
and once you presuppose them there are
an amazing cornucopia all sorts of stuff
falls out
like you have hilbert's hotel that is
completely booked out but there's
infinitely many rooms and then there are
infinitely many buses coming on and you
just ask everybody to move in the room
with twice their number and then you fit
in the infinitely many new people right
this is not a feature
this is a bug
this shouldn't happen
i know how the hotels work no hotels
work like this
this is not good if something like this
happens and uh it's not surprising that
this blows up when you try to make
proofs
and so i think that hilbert's hotel
points not to a miracle in the universe
that under certain circumstances you get
something for nothing which is very nice
if you want to derive a universe from
nothing but
it shows that your language can break
and so i don't see a way to get the
languages in which continuity exists to
work and i cannot exclude that i'm wrong
and i might see a way in the future or
somebody else does in a way that i don't
i just don't see a way how to make
continuity work
but i get all the benefits from
continuity for the description of
practical systems
using discrete logic
so in this sense i would say that
dynamical systems that are truly
continuous don't exist
they're not causally existing they
cannot be causal
they are a layer of description that i
use to deal with too many parts to count
and there are sometimes a very useful
abstraction but they cannot be used for
a foundational theory
because the foundational stuff
has to work it has to be described in a
language where all the element
parts have to interface and stretch away
that your language doesn't blow up
because otherwise the terms in your
language don't mean anything so what
this means is that the word continuity
does not actually mean anything in my
world it does not have a useful
reference i cannot point at anything
that is truly continuous without my
language breaking
so it doesn't exist it's a word that
only exists as a confusion but it exists
approximately it exists as the dynamics
of too many parts to count which is fine
so i'm a confused man and when you say
that the language is breaking i just see
it as you saying that there are
extremely unintuitive results that well
they don't seem to make sense but it
doesn't mean that they don't make sense
because you defined work as what's
implementable now what it doesn't work
means that you can no longer derive
truth it means for instance in an
exomatic system if you have a
contradiction in your axioms
it means that you can certainly derive
everything
and nothing it just means that your
fractal is no longer having a
discernable structure this is what it
means that it's breaking
[Music]
what is the exact contradiction
in classical logic because it seems as
though mathematicians are getting along
fine and it's difficult extremely
difficult to prove certain theorems and
it wouldn't be if there was a
contradiction well not necessarily but
you understand what i mean yes so the
issue is that the assumption of a
stateless platonic notion of truth that
holds independent of the process by
which you discover the truth
leads into contradictions
and this was what goodl had proven it
basically means that the sentence that
is true under these assumptions is also
false under these assumptions so it
cannot be true and this is where
undecidability comes in it just it's not
just about that some sentences are not
reachable because you don't know whether
they're true or false it also means that
there are some sentences that are true
and false at the same time
but if you have to find true inside
truth in such a way that it can that it
includes false falsity right something
is either true or false
if you have an excluded middle then this
cannot be the case so this is a very bad
result it just means that your language
is not working it gets to illegal states
it just means that the application of
steps that you have prescribed in your
logic if you apply them properly leads
to an undefined result
it means that your
language is seg-faulting it means your
mind is breaking apart it means that the
thoughts that you are thinking no longer
have meaning because they can no longer
point to anything that could be
implemented
okay so don the question that i asked
before was let's imagine that
intuitionist logic is correct how does
your theory change
well yeah so
i mean i could easily
implement the theory of conscious agents
you know in an intuitionist logic kind
of approach and and run it that way so
that that wouldn't really change my my
theory of conscious agents
fundamentally but
my
own thinking on this i guess does differ
from yoshi's in in an interesting way
here and that that is
i do take girdles
result
not not necessarily to show that the
notion of continuity
is is nonsense or contradictory
but
rather that if i have a finite system of
axioms
in derivation rules
then
and you can look at the set of
statements that can be proven by that
system and then you can find statements
that that are not provable within the
system that so so they're undecidable
from within that system
but you can what what girdle did was to
to put a mapping
onto the the language of the system so
he could write down
an analogy as this douglas hofstadter
likes to talk about he he found an
analogy that he could write down where
there was this new sent there is a
sentence i could write down
that that says i am true
but not provable within this system
and that that doesn't seem to me to
require me going all the way off to in
to uncountable infinities and continuity
and so forth it's just saying i mean
here's the deflationary reading of
girdle it's just saying you give me any
computational system i'll find a
statement that that's true but can't be
derived from within that system
therefore any computation that you pick
um isn't the final word
i don't have to go all the way to you
know
uncountable sets and so forth i can just
i can just use that to say that the
computation can't be the final truth
um and so that would be uh
sort of the minimal way and
that's why i think a lot of um
researchers have interpreted girdle but
but um i guess you should disagrees on
that
okay what would be the thing that goes
beyond that so what is the other
language that you can use
after good language broke
well what you do is you take the the the
new statement
that that you showed was undecidable
within that
within that computational system and you
add it to your computational system
right every computational system has
axioms you don't compute without some
assumptions so your computation has to
have certain accents to begin with so
you add it to your accent it's now still
a finite set of axioms and now you say
okay now i'm good i i took that
undecidable sentence and i put it into
my set of axioms i'm good now i'm done
well no you're not now because girdle
comes back and says you know what i just
found another statement within your new
system and that's not computable so i'm
not getting anywhere near to these
uncountable infinities now wait wait
wait uh you're making a step too far
here i think you have just found this
procedure that discovers that something
is true that is not
true according to mathematics
so good is trying to find a foundation
for all of mathematics
and he does this by reducing the
mathematics that he's interested in to
piano arithmetic
and then computes all of mathematics in
piano arithmetic and discovers that he
cannot recover the semantics that he
wanted to discover
which was a platonic notion of truth one
that is independent of the state
sequence that he runs it through this is
the thing that you cannot recover and
you try to recover the original
mathematics
by extending uh the exomatic system
piano's axioms with an infinite sent a
set of arbitrary statements this doesn't
seem to be very elegant also of course
google shows that it doesn't terminate
it doesn't work it's not fixing
mathematics in any way
so uh you still have in the intuition
here that you have a procedure that
allows you to discover truth in ways
that gerda's procedure could not
and if you have that procedure you
should be able to prove that it's true
if you cannot prove that it's true i'm
not going to believe you
i don't think that the statements that
you think are true but my system cannot
prove are true
right unless you can compute them right
so you have to show away and that would
force me as a rational uh
observer and colleague of yours that is
completely uh
terrible and so on and reasonable and
rational right to follow you there right
so if you can give me a rational
procedure then i expect that this
procedure
will be computational that it will there
will be a sequence of steps
that i can follow to see why your claim
that this sentence is true is actually
valid
if you cannot make such a claim i i
don't see how i can believe you
well so so the way the do i understand
girdle doing it is that he you know he
comes up with this whole girdle
numbering
approach
and he he takes you through and and
shows you this this mapping from the
from the numbers into these girdle
numbers that are making statements about
the numbers themselves
and you look at that and you go yeah
okay bye i understand that mapping
that's perfectly fine
and now i can write down within that
mapping i can write down this number
and when i look at the interpretation of
that number under this mapping
the the number says
i am true but not provable within piano
and so so now um i mean at this point i
sort of agree with roger penrose
penrose looks at that and says okay that
that means that there is something true
here
um i can see that it's true it's i i
don't disbelieve i mean i saw the whole
girdle numbering construction
i saw how the sentence came to say what
it says and i agree that it's that that
it's all consistent
and what it's saying
is saying that it's true and not
provable
so
so
so at this
point i
i guess i sort of agree with penrose at
that point i go okay there's something
beyond the notion of
proof
beyond the notion of derivation that's
going on here there's the looking at
analogies
um and understanding analogies
that where we go this this sentence is
clearly true and it's also by its own
statement its own declaration that it's
not provable within
within this this finite computational
system yeah
perros is fascinating he thinks that our
brains are physical systems and he also
thinks that our mental processes are
generated by the brain probably
but that our brains can do mathematics
that go beyond the mathematics that
computers can do that is a very specific
statement that is more concrete i think
specific than what you've said so far
sure and uh it leads him to uh
to if a weird spot which is quite lonely
at the moment but i i find this
nevertheless a very interesting argument
to make i'm uh afraid we will not be
able to resolve it today because i have
to drop now yeah but
i found it very interesting to see that
you are appendrosis at the end of the
day
well um i don't like the microtubules
theory you know i don't like the the
non-competitive clusters
he's not really to be blamed for this i
suspect that his reasoning is that since
all neuron physics is computational
these basically takes a state and then
there is a transition between the states
the uh resolution for what consciousness
where it comes from
if the consciousness is enabling us to
do things that computers cannot needs to
be in an unknown area of physics and the
unknown area of physics that's left
reasoning in the same way as sherlock
holmes if you actually exclude all the
possibilities the only remaining thing
must be the truth right that's quantum
gravity because there is no generally
accepted theory of quantum gravity right
right and then it just so happens that
uh hammer off has this beautiful
psychedelic uh theory of uh how to get
the microtubules to have non-local
interactions that employ quantum
gravities in a way that nobody really
understands right right and this might
be in this corner and so uh they they
become friends
but i don't think that penrose theory is
exactly the same thing as hammer of
theory right right right and i'm not
talking about that more general theory
of consciousness i'm just talking about
his specific analysis of girdles
incompleteness theorem and what it means
for mathematics yes
and it's basically uh also something
that uh chomsky is affirming to in which
leads trump's chomsky to mysterianism so
basically they were confronted with the
same
insight or the same idea that they think
that human brains can do things that
mathematics cannot
that mathematicians can make proofs that
computers and principle cannot make that
they discover that certain statements
are true that in a computable exomatic
system cannot be derived and this was
also what my question was pointing out
at uh how do you know that something is
true there if you cannot go show me a
sequence of steps
that that does it right and so uh
penrose and uh
thinks
that there must be unknown physics
and
um swamski things it cannot be
understood in principle which might be
the same thing at the end of the day
right like i guess we will have to go
i'll just say
our basic understanding of the axioms
itself
then maybe one thing to
how do i understand the basic axioms
that are the foundation of the
computational system where does that
understanding come from is that from
within the computational system or does
that ex does that escape the
computational system
from my own perspective it's
the case that my mind is constructing a
model of reality where the reality that
i found myself to be in is something
like a physics engine in which my own
conscious self
acts as a puppet as a simulacrum that is
being used to tell the story about an
intelligent agent
and i don't see any limitations in my
ability to make models that could
produce such an agent that would find
itself in this world and associate a set
of
valence presets with um
a garlic and another one
with sunlight
and
that happens entirely through the
relational nature of my unified model of
the universe that is being derived by
completely non nefarious computation
that are approximated in nervous systems
right so i don't see where i currently
stand uh that this doesn't work out
and i uh
very sympathetic to
when you don't see this
that it doesn't work out and that you
have to uh think that you have to find
the truth elsewhere and it could be that
i am going to change my mind in the
future when i stumble on something that
basically shows to me that that what i'm
intellectually trying doesn't work so as
far it seems to work and uh i appreciate
that we have this difference in our
perspectives because it's a very
productive and useful one to have
absolutely i've really appreciated the
the tenor of the conversation too very
very much so i i would just say my last
thought on this would be that
the what i would love to see from a
computational system on consciousness is
the associated association you just
talked about between the computation and
say the taste of garlic
is it principled or is it arbitrary that
association if it's arbitrary it's then
i'm not yes it's it's not arbitrary it's
related to uh the valence of the taste
receptors that you have so it might be
arbitrary in the sense that some people
hate garlic and other people love garlic
so the garlic will taste different to
them this means they will have a
different experience when they taste
garlic because the relations of the
taste of garlic will be different to the
uh
to the entire world model that they have
than they are to other people so they
basically the types of receptors that we
have in the valence that they imply
and the type of self model that we have
so in which way has the mind constructed
itself that is entangled with its
universe around it what is that boundary
what is the set points that are marking
this boundary that keeps the self stable
this is going to shape and alter the
perception but i don't think that there
is an intrinsic essence of perception
beyond the relations that we establish
between perceptual patterns and our
models of reality
so there'll always be the question why
should this computational
process
independent of valence be the taste of
garlic why couldn't have been the taste
of chocolate i would want a principled
answer to why is this computational
process
necessarily the taste of garlic why
isn't it the taste of chocolate because
one is affiliated to garlic and the
other one is associated to chocolate
but i'm talking about the the conscious
experience of the taste of oh well uh
chocolate is sweet for the most part and
garlic is not
so this is one of the dimensions in
which the features vary and uh sweetness
is perceived as a pleasant under some
circumstances when you need certain
types of nutrients and uh the soreness
and bitterness and sharpness of garlic
is associated with other things that you
might need or dislike at certain moments
so this the valence is crucial that you
get and they are basically um hundreds
or thousands or um tens of thousands of
valence dimensions that specify how we
perceive this texture of the pattern
that uh but the resolution the structure
of the pattern and so on is entirely
given by its its relational nature
i don't think that doesn't present
beyond the relations sound like well
this this is the story of a whole other
round one take care everyone thank you
so much
thank you too
good dog you enjoyed this thank you very
much it's plenty of fun and the audience
is all saying thank you as well i think
there were about a thousand people well
thank you very much
thanks everyone thank you joshua please
send me the mp3 if you don't mind
okay dawn i don't know if you still are
recording yours bye-bye
okay bye-bye take care
thank you all thank you all thank you
all so much for being here
it was plenty of fun there's plenty to
talk about for a round two whenever that
occurs maybe toward the end of the
summer or the middle of summer we'll see
people's willingness and ability
the podcast is now finished if you'd
like to support conversations like this
then do consider going to patreon.com
c-u-r-t
j-a-i-m-u-n-g-a-l that is kurt jaimungle
it's support from the patrons and from
the sponsors that allow me to do this
full-time every dollar helps
tremendously thank you